please welcome tk okonkwo
hello
i have been doing promos saying your
name i've been waiting weeks to like
finally meet you in person and you said
it so beautifully thank you did i did
yeah thanks guys oh your accent my
goodness
i've lived in so long i forget i have an
accent actually but i definitely do no
your voice is like everything thanks and
i'm not the only person who thinks this
is it true that you're on the calm app i
am yeah i read millions of people to
sleep
every every night
okay
now your new show labrea is a smash hit
yeah it just got picked up for season
two
[Applause]
[Music]
this show is a trippy it is it is
especially if you live or have spent
time in l.a because you know this giant
sinkhole opens up and i think people who
are in that city seem to take it a
little bit too seriously maybe like
could this happen any moment now i lived
like off la brea so yeah it's literally
where i lived where i grew up
but i mean when they're talking about a
show like this
were you like excited did you know that
they were gonna tackle the tone so well
because it's working it's a huge success
season two but that's it's like hard to
pull this off it is i i was so
blown away by david applebaum the show's
creator and his huge vision for the show
and i just felt like it's fun you know
you get to go and just be adventurous
and just like run around running away
from things running towards things
trying to get back it was a really big
undertaking and like you say it's kind
of tough as well but it was so much fun
we had such a great cast and great crew
down in australia where we shoot and it
was just yeah a real family sort of job
we all got in there and just did it
together it was great and we were
filming you know outside in the elements
for six months through an australian
winter which is actually very cold um i
wasn't expecting that but it was a lot
of fun as well like i say and uh
thankfully we didn't get to see any
dangerous animals although it was nice
when kangaroos would jump by our
trailers and that really happened and
that really happened several several
days in a row yeah
okay so you're coming out of your
trailer and you're like what's up
kangaroo
um
and then but it wasn't there a story
that like not having to do with the show
you had like a a bear or something yeah
so i i moved to new york about 10 years
ago lived here for a couple years
couldn't take the winters so i moved to
los angeles
and my first month in la friends of mine
we went up to sequoia to go camping oh
yeah which was beautiful um but we had
some survival skills in our group
thankfully because someone had the idea
to tie up our food in a tree in the top
of a tree away from our camp in case
bears were around
and so we did that we tight we climbed
up a tree tied our food at the top got
back in our tents and went to bed for
the night and um then all i could hear
was this
sort of snorting outside of our tent wow
and i was just terrified for the whole
night i didn't sleep a single wink and
it was freezing cold as well and
just petrified to see what might be
there when we got out but thankfully
when we got there the bear had gone um
and our food was okay so i think if our
food had been in our camp it might have
been a different story oh my god i so
know that i would be that dippy valley
girl
who would just leave all her food on the
floor and get mauled by bears like that
would be it
that would be it i'm so glad that wasn't
yours
the case for you oh no that's exactly
what would happen um because i know
nothing about camping will you ever go
camping again i think i will i enjoyed
it i'm like
freezing and
a warmer time of year and
maybe the bears will leave us alone
maybe i learned some skills on the show
i don't know but um i don't want to put
those to the test actually um all right
well i would love if you wouldn't mind
if we could talk um about your dad um we
have this thing here on the show called
good dad's program
and i love honoring great dads you know
i just
moms get a lot of attention um which is
fantastic and very well deserved but i
like to honor dad's here too
so um
you did a post and it was
so beautiful
and touching about your father and i was
wondering if i could ask you about it
yeah of course so my dad um
grew up in nigeria but moved to europe
when he was very young to get an
education and
was
just the most present father that i
could ever have wished for i've got
siblings i'm one of four my older sister
younger sister and younger brother and
he was just very very present but he
passed away when i was 24
my younger brother was only 13 so young
for us to lose a dad but he
i feel like the more years that passed
by the more lessons i learned from him
and from the memory of him
i actually moved to new york
exactly five years after he passed
and
last friday was exactly 15 years so it's
nice to have these landmark moments and
it's just so nice to be
living my dream because he was so
encouraging of it he always wanted me to
come to america and to do my work here
so i'm really glad that i did that and
i've followed through
do you think he's proud
yeah i definitely do and it's so nice to
have you know a big show that people are
watching and paying attention to and all
the other things that we have going on
and um i i often think that he would be
very very proud and and you bring him
into it yeah definitely um i actually
have here
the text
that you wrote if you have any interest
in reading it yeah of course would you
mind do you think we could have not only
your beautiful voice but um the way that
you honor your father in this is
something we would be honored if you
would share bless you um i wrote my i am
my father's son
he taught me the value of family of
perseverance of consistency he also
taught me to love and respect the women
around me
as i look at this version of myself
pictured i feel grateful because i know
the only reason he made it to today is
because of the powerful women in his
life
[Applause]
[Music]
and as we honor
men and great dads the reciprocity of
honoring women is just so full circle
may we all
love and respect and appreciate each
other absolutely i'm glad i got through
that without crying so thanks
[Laughter]
i'm so grateful anyone who knows me
knows i'm a crier at any given
opportunity so well if we didn't love
you enough by the way
like clap of hands i love women
show emotion
i love honoring good dads and just you
know really celebrating every individual
out there like i just thank you for
sharing i thank you for giving me the
opportunity to that's just honestly so
so beautiful and on his 15-year
anniversary as well of his passing so
it's just really meaningful to me and my
family thank you thank you for bringing
him into the room with us
thank you
thank you tk so much the season finale
of la brea airs tonight at 9 8 central
on nbc
[Music]